[Music]  Kim and Khloe Kardashian shut down the  NBCUniversal upfronts red carpet  literally they were the last to arrive  and stunned in coordinating fashions  Khloe went to sleek in some  figure-hugging pants in a lingerie  inspired top while kim afloat at her  assets in a geometric blouse with some  floral detail how was your Mother's Day  inside the sisters took the stage to  talk Keeping Up with the Kardashians and  today view the trailer for little sis  Kylie Jenner's new show life of Kylie  take a look this show is a gift for my  fans I heard you needed a date for prom  so I'm here  the duo feels pressure to not let  anybody down nobody has a perfect life I  am not totally innocent because I am  keeping up this lifestyle I can't do it  forever  this isn't keeping up with the  kardashians this is like a therapy  session now I can find what really is  gonna make me happy I'm Kylee and this  is my life  [Music]  you